some breaking news now U.S President Joe
Biden's son has been indicted on federal
firearms charges Hunter Biden is accused
of lying about his drug use when he
illegally bought a gun in 2018. he's
also been under investigation for his
business dealings and failing to pay
taxes the indictment comes as
Congressional Republicans pursue an
impeachment inquiry into President
Biden's alleged involvement in Hunter
Biden's foreign business ventures
on our White House correspondent
Kimberly halkett joins us live now
Kimberly what more can you tell us on
this developing situation
well what I can tell you is that we have
been expecting there was the potential
for these charges against the
president's son now they have been
leveled against Hunter Biden at least in
regards to these gun charges and we can
tell you that these are the most
consequential if he is convicted so far
against Hunter Biden this is as you
mentioned the result of a long time
investigation by special counsel David
Weiss a trump appointee we should point
out and we should point out as well that
uh Hunter Biden could have avoided much
of this if his plea deal from July was
successful that ultimately fell apart
and now not only is he facing these gun
charges but he could potentially also be
facing tax evasion charges as well those
could be imminent filed either in
California potentially or in Washington
state now the timing in all of this as
you mentioned not particularly good for
Joe Biden the president given the fact
that this white house has gone to Great
pains to make light of and even to
characterize the Republicans on Capitol
Hill and their impeachment inquiry into
not only Joe Biden but his son Hunter
Biden's business dealings that
investigation into whether or not Hunter
Biden had essentially sold access to Joe
Biden when he was vice president in the
Barack Obama administration not only
profiting some alleged four million
dollars from not only Ukraine but also
China and the White House has really
tried to say there's no basis in fact
there's no merit to this the fact that
they have now had this case two days
later is really going to make the White
House have a little bit more difficulty
and at least the court of public opinion
making that case that there is really no
basis in fact for that investigation so
this is going to be a challenge for this
white house it's going to be a challenge
for Joe Biden politically as he runs for
a second term in office and it's also a
challenge now for of course Hunter Biden
who has to not only face the potential
of this impeachment inquiry
investigation but also has to face these
Court charges and the potential not only
for the uh the legal case of these uh
these gun charges but potentially an
additional legal challenge in terms of
tax evasion as well
Kimberly thanks very much indeed for
that update